I think the funny thing is like I'm a
nobody in terms of how people measure
somebody's I'm definitely in the nobody
crew happily so when people see that I
make a shell and have some kind of
famousy people on it and they see that
I'm going to be telling other stories
then they want to get hats so they say
hi here's my reel I'd love to be on your
show and that is the first thing that
they have ever said to me on Twitter and
so I say have you seen my show and then
they say no and then I say why do you
want to be on a show that you have never
seen and then they say well it's got to
be dude because it has all those people
in it and then I say have you ever seen
anybody famous who's a good actor do
I have so maybe I'm maybe I created
and I got all these good people to be in
a shitty show that you just has to be
cast in because you're dumb enough to
not look at a show before you asked to
be in it also you're insulting me
because I put my heart and soul blood
and guts money I wrote it I directed it
I ended it there are billions of
hours on the thing and you just show up
with one sweet mommy - watch your 17
minute improv real and cast you and why
you to Los Angeles what do you think
that is done you would walk up to
somebody around oh hi here's my real I
know we've never met hi here's my real
just walk around hi here's my real
highest and then and I had an actor so
but people don't follow me on the street
this is an Internet exactly and don't
forget that the Internet
as human beings there's a human being
behind all those accounts so when you go
hi here's my hi here's one hi why is
that not spam because this is the thing
is you only see I'm just one actor just
asking you for one I understand I'm a
member of side I've done the dumb head
love to be in your I've done it I
understand it but what I'm saying is you
can be smarter you can be don't have the
self respect to look at a project before
you ask to be in it are you just so
desperate to be in anything
because you want to be in anything and
you know what that's not fun to work
with that Despero that all I'd love to
be in it because it exists thank you for
making it Kennedy in it never saw it
don't know if it's good I have no
respect for my ability as an actor I'd
like to be in things it's pornography oh
I didn't look at it that's I should have
looked at that yeah so just just ball
people and I've done it I'll pitch to
people I've tweeted it watch my thing
much more thing most the time it doesn't
work most of the time it's and if you
say look at my reel and then I go back
to your feed and I see that you've asked
50 people
hi look at my real hi look at my real hi
look at my real and then I accuse you of
spamming and then you start
rationalizing to me what you're trying
to do you're still not facing the back
your spam your spam you're on Twitter
and you're just
it's family
and nobody I don't like spam I don't
like to create spam I have to market I
have to push I understand but I think
relax a little bit hang out
it's just Twitter it's just people we're
all just talking some of them are famous
for cares most of them are it's
200 million people on Twitter something
like that but just relax have a cup of
coffee talk to people say hi finally we
can all be human beings let's stop let's
start doing that and stop being in the
marketing the spam machines we're trying
to network and like you're walking
around the whole world every day hello
my name is hello my name is just last
and at least look at my work before you
has to be it just show me that because
now I have to look at your work to
decide if you're gonna be in my work and
you haven't looked at my work that's not
fair
you